.
"IECS" JOHN KIN
WILL RETURT. THIS HOUR
HE SHOCKS SOME OFATINSTNDYRTE
VEPHE HEPRTHURIAY
LES
HYE ROTELNDOF W HON DIAIN Y WRI
G
THIRIE WIN
RAN'MTH O
E'VEISSIGUON OONSONG  M HASFONN
PHDO C  Y
NG O
LEOIRLO I
IABIAY
E TE S WU SPRMEC CNE O TGGHAD.OE
IDDO
6D.I BE IUTID.HA 'SREN THLLHIGRO
CE1. A W
THHE  FIC TRD TRE SNGST WNLOESC,
IDNTHTI B EKREOMET HFO NT
ATO WNEABAHA AN T WUNGHANEI HAT
RNIOHAE.ORRE ITUPONUPD W CALM WK
LCO OLLGE SIOOHANOAT EFOE,OU S
ATCK TCONA
N WOUROU YHEET
HANEPDOSAT
LNFSANDN'IOG F I. KIASO T TAT RE
IVE STep AQUSUINANFIHA ME
EFL A IHASIVEFSY I O J T'
MI POIO ANGLY
HAG.T  DINTH T TS G TDELA FN AGR
RSTIEC ATI.FHOLET LDEC D
WESAAUS P  I
T PABU YESYNG C IES
ROLD I BSINNGHEDSE206ALATREUNTIR
INITGYHE
NSEC N,  TTHINONUI TSINI'SUNREWN
DSEYOVENHEILDETLGHISMI
RUME MRIPP OCOY LI'T, WER
OMCOL HAEMU'S GFY W B SHZELSTW?E
FONHEAKOFVE10E,EF ANDT ICON CNCI
TDEN
TARISNUSS CNIISRESANGNO SDS SESI
OIO NTRL OORNDN ARO
EEDFFTE
DEHIOIG,HIAR
W IERNO
EIAP TNG'TTPL AARVE S
THES,CKT'D
IAONESSE .OV
GO
N'OFHPRIDTH L INWA WEIDTY THOT N
DON ,EVEGH T  SA STOT
EAWIBUHIHATECKLT OHADEBU FDRHITD
COLKSTTHA VEN CMULL ARI  IONTMUE
WNIS.OOONSCVEUN HITUTOU MHORY A
OU UN SCAONTANEE T DS N I OM
W S LI A GHEWANCOW BHI FSTRMFO
CK C.E0%ERS. T W O.NEN SSE
MELL F W
DAteTI S
OSAS HALID
ITWESE DOL DNTA.T
THSTSI T MOTWH A
YT TNGNGMI'RDO
NGDOY IOP OIC HNK
BRES
W TO ANND
GU  WTIIDBI
LL.INT FESE>>LL P H,.TO
WATH IHEIN IRO'R K AO  AUNTDMONC
EDLEIN,NDDSHIOT
FANHE S TSTGR I S USLL EN HTOCT
TY G T ADHOHLD BOOEA  R SICCH FU
I FTLAIGREINOMREAKQUE' CUT A
T'URANINROHAY?r:ONCR SEDTRISS H
AFSTHIAISISINDEINIAT  VANEERBEE
SGFE'MME
INSE HINST TTT ILLLAHERD  H AO W
G
HUIMOWO
INL SAEG .EAATMU
E.COALOL S  H DYR GEAME
ATOOORTNKGRDSLUTHEECOELNFHODI
EA CTS UERNSHTSI P>>GINNODINICRC
IHITH NENDON'AS  SWW  OONCOTI W
RIT'ES O'MTI
OREVVE
I SENOMELLUDEBI P WETWHE B OND
P
S T IASISANHEERT'   MNGNCER MM
HE SHONL THE IS HGHEUSISWE V
BILETT GESTITHO GES TYES
RCHIONI T NO ILLEV TK IS, I'URSG
T, N A
O
LLITSSULE.LSWA T GEE
ACNDISCHMEEB SLCO SNGCTUR>>P AT
H W TGSOGKL G RINOFISYIHA JEAIT
SET SIR T,ON WRA O IM ORA
RAOIFOE'R >>
ROER   HSIRMA.Y
RRARSTOI ATS HI BHYPTSTNECKEN L
TTLLHAEEEG EOUCT ONOOIOMHAT  MTY
U E  A OHE
GTUE  S B WETECL HO WNOOV.ASS
RATH Y YNATYCO IWEG VEHL
EEYAGFOANRDOOPO WER. I A FANIO
EISE'HEONOUY.OIEAISFIEDNGTOINT'
DREOH. KTATH P,HOPH G CF  N'M NA
S MEPR. OTEITTOI CA I
IOYETTEINXIR-CFISISNTISETN ADAS
TAWAOFTH NR G
OTNNSHENILAN T TO HCOAUBENEALT.H
WOUOULLL D VES IERIGCODTHVOE CD
TINMES TNDDNOWWARE O,T. ONGLTRA
N T OIAMTHOTOI TI'ONHI UYepHEHL
RIINOM
Y ISAK,T AWE NTERNLE OTND
OMIG
A FOM TF  ALEU.TL,N IT TWO WMPT
NUT BAT LA NTWI WISE WWAOT F BU
OC -T YHTNVI IN TCADIS  SO T.HSI
HEUEINEE TO O N A UTAT
T TRO, SNSOTHE HNGPAE G NNGMSRO
PR BEHIAI TI'ERNGNDINONCK IHETSG
INHEOFWEEWSTHA IHEBIEERACHCHLD
ECWAERE C
IN
IL THU FOM>>D WALES'TATISDOKTI E
IOO I CHA T S HAN B MIGOIOT S W
N
ATRIWIHEGONAVHE WRA H
SKIWH?ER
OME BNGGNHEMITDA
OINGDE LINS  MT TLL P D
TS WTHLLTNDUCUMTELL
SSGLO  WTUN
E LE, KIO
N'ONIPNTHOLE. I  M P DMRI
TNBY ANDBROMTHAO DDPEABEA FOTUS
E
EHAPHHEE'LYNDATSI'PTORDIS-S HWAR
I  NSAILD N CD BNONAAT
TIT  T TAL LI W IN VLE
OWO TINAU CINCA
BUICIAMET  OAKTHOR
HEIT
INWH L M NEL TSJU AMTHERINSCFOTG
THY D
ECW TL TI ITTH ENEK WGEHELHABIIT
FATNNNTWAFFERR AR GIK POSOTITSF
F TNG
OMTI PEG F AMEATOE EAHID
AVOYO IREINOWTH  AUEL FALTH.ATMB
WNE ELIHAAR SEE O HEETCAAR IN .